Israel kills enough of these sons of
that this is not a problem again
whenever anyone suggests that Israel is
willfully killing civilians that is the
most ignorant bigoted anti-semitic bull
ever said there cannot be a ceasefire
anyone who calls for a ceasefire is a
terrorist sympathizer under these
circumstances what have you been smoking
boy huh why you been
smoking how are you guys doing it's been
a very volatile time because of the
conflict and it's been something which
has really been I'll be honest
infuriating me it's making the entire
Muslim umah sad it's making us very
angry at the same time today I'm going
to be refuting Ben Shapiro I've refuted
him in the past and I'm going to be
refuting him again but before I do so I
just want to make something very clear a
lot of the people that are coming out
and discussing some of the protests and
some of the demonstrations or whatever
that are being conducted by some Pro
Palestinian sympathizers are framing it
as some kind of celebration for the
civilian deaths on the Jewish side now
what I'll say is this unequivocally
first of all that's slander quite
frankly and prop Palestinian ism is not
equatable with anti-Semitism it's not
equatable with celebrations for Hamas
it's not killing civilians or whatever
it may be it's not equated with any of
those things at all and the flag of
Palestine doesn't symbolize and it will
not symbolize and it cannot symbolize
and it has not symbolized yeah civilian
death or the celebration of Civilian
death we don't celebrate and this is a
caveat I'm going to make a disclaimer
that I am going to make yes we do not
celebrate any death of any civilian from
any religion or any background no man no
woman no child and that is not despite
the Islamic teachings that is because of
the Islamic teachings yes the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
unequivocally told us that the killing
of women of children the mutilating of
bodies and so on and so forth all of
those things are
unacceptable and this is all in
narrations and Hadith which
are which are authoritative and
authentic so there's no doubt about that
and you can go back to my Twitter feed
where I put those hadiths in the Arabic
language in which you can translate for
your own convenience so don't try it
don't try and smear us don't try and
slander us don't try and attack don't
try and produce red earrings now let's
go and talk about this
situation first and foremost I'll say
yes we condemn any woman child or
whatever it may be that's being killed
who's Jewish and who's not a
non-combatant but why is it the case Ben
huh why is it the case that you none of
your colleagues or you have been able to
offer one single condolence one single
condemnation one single word of sympathy
for any of the Gins that have been
killed throughout the 16 years of
blockade in the open air prison that is
called Gaza the suffocating conditions
the gag conditions that have been put in
place why is it that you have not been
able to
apologize apologize for supporting the
IDF who have perpetrated such actions
knowing full well that when they do so
they will disproportionately kill
civilian
people why is it that in the imagination
of the Western Med media when someone is
killed who is a Jew who has Li a
European Jew frankly a European Jew who
has lighter skin huh that that must be
cried about and all the leaders must say
something but that if the Palestinian
children if the
Palestinian women if the Palestinian
elderly are bombarded actually the
blessings are given not only that
encouragement is given for such a
thing tell me why give me a reason
the first thing I want to respond to is
something that you mentioned in your
video talk about amalik now for those
who don't understand who Amica Amica a
group that I mention the Hebrew Bible or
the Old
Testament and if someone knows for
example the the book of Samuels 1st
Samuel chapter
15:3
huh then we'll know that there is a
genocidal
prescription now why is Ben Shiro
mentioning amalik let's take a look at
the video it it did not matter just as
um in the Bible describes it describes
Amal as uh as praying on the weak and
the
elderly that uh this is this is what
they do as you can see here now he's
trying to Preamble his discussion by
talking about amalik now who are amalik
here is it Hamas or is it the
Palestinians this is my question because
you you've kept it quite vague here
you've kept it quite vague here because
if we look at the Old Testament it says
that go go and kill the men the women
the children The Oxen the sheep and even
the
ass and even the ass and I think you're
an ass a jack ass that's what you are
that's what you are because you're
talking as we'll see you you're crying
with alligated tears you're
crying about the death of the civilians
on the Jewish side but not one word is
spoken not one word is spoken about any
of the suffering on the other side we
can't take you seriously let's take a
look at what you say you say three times
this is what evil looks like again we
all have to watch this this is what evil
looks like it's what evil looks like
it's what evil looks like it's what evil
looks like okay this is what evil looks
like I agree if a child is killed and
this is a big if by the way
in these reports the Quran says if
someone comes to you with a new
if an evildoer comes to you and you are
the biggest evildoers with a news then
you have to verify a lot of the stuff
that's coming out we don't even know for
sure if that's happening or not but for
the sake of argument some of it we can
say Beyond reasonable diet is happening
and we condemn no problem any person
that's a non-combatant woman child
whatever we condemn the killing of that
person having said that having you said
this is what evil looks like you're
saying that's what evil looks like but
when it comes to the images that you're
seeing in Gaza that's not what evil
looks like that's not what evil looks
like let's take a look at exhibit
a that's not enough for you let's take a
look at exhibit
B statistically and objectively if you
look at all the operations that have
been done operation castled Operation
protective Edge the 2021 operation
and then this operation all of those
operations in the 16 years that Gaza has
been blockaded how many Palestinians
have died how many civilians have died
ask me answer me that question how many
civilians have died how many women have
died how many children have died how
many in 16 years how many thousands and
thousands and thousands thousands and
not one tear not one word spoken because
you know what you prefer the blood of
your children the Jewish children
Israeli children over the blood of ours
full stop how could you not condemn the
IDF from doing these bombardments when
they know full well that
if they do these bombardments they would
disproportionately kill women and
children they do these bombardments
therefore they disproportionately kill
women and children don't say that is
using them as human Shields Hamas is
using like what every single member of
Hamas has got a child in front of him
like that and holding him like this is
this the comic book picture that you're
trying to portray here 2.2 million
civilians are there even enough Hamas to
go around and hold them as human Shields
like that a child are you dumb are you
crazy and why are you trying to portray
as if the only way that there can be an
offensive an attack and defending as you
call it Israel has to defend why are you
making it seem as if that's the only way
through aerial
bombardment where the where the vast
majority of people that are going to be
killed are going to be men women and
children are
non-combatants surely there can be boots
on ground you can be a man the IDF can
be Men Real Men Real Brave real Gallant
real courageous which is something you
can't fathom or don't know anything
about you have no fortitude at all you
have not shown any ability to engage
with people even on an intellectual and
conversational level that's how lacking
of fortitude that you you
are why don't they go face to
face with w w with Hamas fight them why'
you have to kill the child why did you
have to kill the woman oh it's it's said
100% collateral damage and all of the
generals that I've been seeing us yeah
collateral damage they've been asked by
the Western media collateral damage
collateral damage coll it's going to be
the worst thing one of them says the
worst thing since World War II and
you're talking to me about the Holocaust
when you have one of your Commander is
telling yeah it's going to be the worst
thing since the Holocaust
effectively and we're not talking about
Hamas we're talking about children here
we're talking about women here we're
talking about elderly
people you make me sick you make me
sick but what's even worse is that you
go on to talk about the Palestinians and
you and you deny you deny that it's even
an apartheid state let's take a look at
what you say now let me point out at
this point there is no aparti 20% of
Israel's population is Arab so you deny
that Israel is an apartheid state why
don't you look at any factual definition
of what aparti is a partide is when
there's discrimination based on race a
good example of that is South Africa in
a state are you telling me J was not a
parte are you telling me what happened
inik jar when there was
dispossession when the when there was
detainment when there was not a fair
chance for the for the Muslim
Palestinians or not even Muslims could
be any Palestinian Christian even that
they would not have a fair Judiciary
crack at the whip you're telling me this
is
equivalent to this this guy's rights are
equivalent to these guys's rights are
you dumb are you mad are you
crazy what have you been smoking boy huh
why you been
smoking your voice is so high you been
Tak some helium are you crazy are you
mad don't go there and what's even worse
is that you go further than this you
talk about the annexation listen to this
this this guy who thinks he's talking
about he's calling everyone else Nazis
but he he seems to have the most
fascistic and authoritarian dictatorial
prescriptions he's calling everyone else
all of his Rivals as Nazis the Hamas
Nazis this Nazis that one Nazis the
leftwing Nazi Y and what your
prescribing are effectively
authoritarian dictatorship type Nazi
type policies
let's take a look at what you talk about
when you talk about the
annexation of Gaza whether Israel
annexes the Gaza Strip as damn well
should because the Palestinians have
proved themselves incapable of
self-governance in the Gaza Strip by
allowing Kamas to overrun them now this
is uh beggar belief really either you
don't understand how the political
system of certain countries and states
work you're blissfully ignorant or
you're intentionally ignorant or you're
trying to fool the ignorant either way
ignorance must feature in this analysis
ignorance must feature in this
analysis if you're saying that Israel is
not an apartheid state but then in the
next breath you are recommending Annex
formal annexation through Conquest which
as you know is against international law
but you don't care about international
law forget international law no problem
don't call your your don't call your
country a democracy don't call your
country a pluralistic place or or a
liberal place don't be stupid you're
calling for annexation because the
Palestinians cannot are not capable of
of of choosing the right people so you
must make the decision for them don't
you Ben you must make the decision for
them are you are you
okay are you
okay and what's shocking is that those
protectors the Bastion the archetypes
the personifications The Walking freedom
of speech advocates
who are with you at the daily wi none of
them are saying wait wait a minute
doesn't this def deny self-determination
isn't this against constitutional
American rights that we speak about so
much none of your friends have told you
wait a minute let's rephrase this a
little bit so it can be in line with
maybe some constitutional principles
that we espousing elsewhere that were
advocating elsewhere that were speaking
about elsewhere how could this be in
line with democracy how could this be
because that's what you preach so why
don't you practice what you preach but
no it's Palestinians as the I don't know
what his name is the politicians they're
Human animals
right they're Human animals so they can
have to be treated as a second not even
no determination
self-determination okay fine have it
your way but don't call yourself not an
aparti State you're an AP parde State
don't pretend to be a liberal democracy
do not pretend to be a liberal democracy
and don't call other people Nazis when
your prescriptions are nistic and
fascistic in
nature I don't know how the general
public in
America most of which believe in a kind
of constitutionalism a kind of democracy
the majority how could they tolerate
this Behavior it must be that
dehumanization has reached a critical
boiling point critical mass it has to
have reached critical mass where these
people now honestly their death and the
images that we saw in the beginning of
this video are inconsequential it must
be that they're inconsequential
absolutely sickening and
disgusting and I think you've been
watching a lot of my videos because
you're starting to use my vernacular he
has an unfortunate history of being
pusillanimous about all this
pusillanimous I don't know of any better
word to describe you a person who's been
challenged in debate for debate for a
very very long time and all you can
approach as a college student just like
the IDF cowardly you're cowardly because
the IDF one low risk High reward and for
them a high reward is high CI civilian
casualties where they're pressing
buttons in in Planes when they're very
safe but they don't want face Toof face
confrontation what I mean why haven't we
seen boots on ground this is absolutely
cowardly Behavior why is there aerial
bombardment which affects uh a majority
of of civilians why are you advocating
this you're a coward the IDF are cowards
no doubt about it no doubt about it
pamus you're
Theus you're P I can't see a bigger puss
than you cannot think of a bigger puss
than you don't use that term as if
you've got something any kind of
fortitude walking around of security
guards
everywhere made me sick
Sal